When we look at a scene, we can't always tell how far away objects are. Our
eyes, well at least my eyes, are not laser scanners. They don't return z depths
directly to my brain. Maybe another way to say it, is that we're not bats and
don't use sonar. Our eyes detect what is called the radiance coming from each
direction. Our brain figures out distances from a variety of visual cues. We're
not even particularly aware of these cues. For example, it wasn't until the
renaissance that painters figured out that distant mountains had a blue tinge,
and so started to paint them that way. However, the actual amount of light from
those distant mountains is a given amount of radiance. We don't store depth.
One way to think about radiance is in terms of a function called the light
field. The idea of the light field is that for any point in the universe, and
for all directions from that point there is an incoming radiance value that we
can record. Say we're sitting at a desk. For our location we can look around
and see a color in any direction. In computer graphics terms, we're recording a
radiance for each different, specific direction we look. To form an image, we
find the radiance coming through each pixel. Imagine we have a sensor floating
in space that can move anywhere and look in any direction. I like to think of
the sensor mounted on a turret, with the turret rotating as needed. The
question to you is, how many numbers, how many variables do we need to specify
our imaginary sensor's location and direction so that we can record the light
traveling through any point in the universe from any direction?